una región rusa 40 km de la frontera con
Ucrania vivió ataques transfronterizos
perpetrados según las autoridades por
saboteadores el mismo ha dejado heridos
civiles y algunos edificios destruidos
la situación actual es que ocho personas
resultaron heridas según información del
Ministerio de salud y del Ministerio de
defensa no hubo víctimas civiles una vez
más las situaciones tensa y lo sigue
siendo Se declaró una operación
antiterrorista
desde Rusia responsabilizaron a kiev
quien admitió que sigue de cerca los
hechos pero se desligó de la autoría un
medio ucraniano citando a la
inteligencia militar nacional informó
que los responsables son dos grupos
armados rusos opositores a Vladimir
Putin el cuerpo de voluntarios rusos y
la legión de la libertad de Rusia un
portavoz de este último dijo que era el
momento de liberar al país no es hora de
acabar con la dictadura del kremlin
Muchas gracias a todos los que nos
apoyan que nos envían donaciones y que
están atacando donde hace falta su apoyo
es lo que nos recuerda cada día Nuestro
objetivo final
en la plaza roja sean valientes y no
tengan miedo porque estamos volviendo a
casa Rusia será libre
el gobernador
anunció que gran parte de la población
fue evacuada y se puso en marcha una
operación antiterrorista lo que amplía
los poderes para limitar actividades
restringir la circulación o interrumpir
los servicios de comunicación